[Musique]
bonsoir à tous et bienvenue dans ce set
8 sport c'est parti pour le sommaire en
val plaisir remporté une belle victoire
à domicile ce week-end les plaisirs oies
se sont imposés contre thionville à
l'occasion de la 11e journée du
championnat de nationale 3 les détails
dans ce set 8 sport rugby une victoire
arrachée au bout du suspense en fédérale
3 verset remporté au forceps une
précieuse victoire contre bobigny équipe
est en course pour le top 4 en fin de
saison le résumé à suivre sports de
combat la ministre des sports annoncé
qu'elle souhaitait légaliser la pratique
des arts martiaux mixtes en france une
grande nouvelle pour les amateurs du mma
et notamment les pratiquants évinois
nous recevrons deux adeptes dans ce
magazine l'actualité sportive de la
semaine c'est maintenant sur tv 78
[Musique]
on commence donc par du handball plaisir
a réalisé la belle opération de ce
week-end dans le championnat de
nationale 3 les plaisirs oies ont réussi
à battre thionville un concurrent direct
pour le maintien le résumé du match des
images de nicolas landry une victoire où
les doutes les jaune et noir de plaisir
devait impérativement battre thionville
à domicile ce samedi 25 janvier pour
s'éloigner de la zone de relégation
ce match de nationale 3 commence
pourtant mal pour les locaux les
visiteurs mènent rapidement 9 à 6 face à
des plaisirs wa sans solution là j'avoue
que je n'ai pas trop d'explications sur
les quatre cinq premières minutes
autre que
on a l'impression que la température
qu'il fait ici il était gelé et que les
lorrains ont un peu plus habitudes ont
démontré ce problème mais pas
d'explication au que psychologique où je
sais pas franchement on est resté dans
les starting blocks après un sursaut de
plaisir les deux équipes réparties
finalement aux vestiaires sur le score
de 14 partout très mal dans le match on
prend ce qu'on défend pas on défend pas
correctement mais pas assez de
profondeur on va pas les chercher à théo
et derrière dès qu'on a récupéré le
ballon n'a pu les monte donc c'est pour
ça qu'on obtient un match nul en
première mi temps
en deuxième période plaisir accélère et
se détachent les joueurs comptent
jusqu'à dix buts d'avancé après 15
minutes de jeu sur ville ne reviendra
pas au score final 30 à 24
ça fait du bien d'avoir d'avoir les
trois points parce que c'était
l'objectif en gagnant ce match on leur
passe devant au classement et niveau
comptable ça fait vraiment du bien donc
au final la manière passer en second
plan et on voit qu'on fait une
excellente deuxième mi-temps pour la
finalité c'est bien pour le groupe 1 aux
classements plaisir est aujourd'hui 8,6
avec un point de plus que son adversaire
du jour et s'éloigne de la zone de
relégation prochain match pour confirmer
ce samedi 1er février contre villemomble
toujours à domicile ont joué également
nationale 2 féminine à montigny le
bretonneux a réussi à s'imposer sur le
terrain du paris saint germain ce week
end lésiné montaigne se sont imposés 36
à 32 avec notamment neuf buts de la
joueuse nina jerry cheech cette victoire
permet à montigny le bretonneux de
s'installer sur le podium du championnat
à quatre points de la première place
prochain match le 8 février prochain
contre aulnay on ouvre maintenant une
page football dans le championnat de
national troyes versailles a engrangé sa
dixième victoire de la saison et
versailles et sont allés s'imposer sur
le terrain de créteil lusitanos sur la
plus petite des marges 1 0
au classement les joueurs de la cité
royale sont toujours premier avec quatre
points d'avancé sur ivry quelques étages
plus bas en première division de
district ont joué pour le compte de la
12e journée du championnat voisin
s'impose 2 à 1 face au pecq maurepas est
allé chercher une précieuse victoire à
l'extérieur sur le score de 1 0
bailly noisy bas carrière grésillons 3le
chesnais s'incline contre sartrouville
de un bois d'arcy et aubergenville des
arbres et courez gargenville se séparent
sur le même score 2 partout le
championnat est toujours dominé par
gargenville devant un mort
pas une information à mercato à présent
arrivé à lens en janvier 2018 de walid
mesloub joueur originaire de trappes a
quitté les rangs des sang et or
le club l'a libéré de son contrat le
milieu de terrain de 34 ans a pu
s'engager avec le club qatari d'umm
salal walid mesloub n'a disputé que 10
matchs avec lens cette saison au qatar
il a déjà délivré une passe décisive
pour son premier match on continue à
part du rugby versailles réalisé une
belle opération dans le championnat de
fédérale 3 les versailles se sont
imposés 16 à 13 ans un match à suspense
contre bobigny et peuvent espérer une
belle fin de saison
le résumé du match avantage de à xavier
jamais un choc au programme de cette
14ème journée de fédérale 3 versailles
recevait bobigny au stade de
porchefontaine deux équipes au coude à
coude dans la course au top 4 en fin de
saison
malmenés en début de match les versets
et concède rapidement des points et sont
menés 13 à 0 au bout de 22 minutes de
jeu les bleus arrivent à revenir dans la
partie avec un drop inscrit le score à
la pause 13 à 3 premières pas de
compliqué parce qu'on savait pas ce que
il n'était pas fatigué c'était début du
match on savait que ça allait être très
dense et qu'ils allaient nous mettre de
l'impact physique on a un peu subi en
première mi temps voit le niveau du défi
physique qu'ils étaient plus lourds que
nous donc on a vraiment eu du mal à les
faire tomber
en seconde période verseille pousse à la
faute les jours de bobigny et marque un
essai
[Musique]
et versez y reviennent à hauteur après
cette pénalité marque cette nouvelle
pénalité dans les dernières minutes du
match
score final 16 à 13 pour versailles et
maintenant il n'y a plus rien qui nous
arrêtent et il n'y a plus rien qui nous
paraît très très très fiers de vous les
gars ont du coeur ils ont trouvé des
solutions et avec du mouvement et
d'intensité on a réussi à passer devant
sur la fin de match
versailles est désormais troisième avec
41 points et peut rêver plus grand s'est
passé quelque chose franchement on
savait que c'était un tournant
on est contents si on maîtrise bien la
suite de la saison je pensais à quelque
chose à jouer une qualification est
envisageable
on n'osait pas trop en parler mais avec
ce second bloc il faut s'accrocher 1
s'est pas fait mais on y pense pour
continuer à poursuivre leur bonne série
les versailles i se déplaceront sur le
terrain de vincennes le 16 février
prochain
on continue à parler rugby dans le
championnat de fédérale 2 plaisir a eu
chaud mais le club s'offrent une bouffée
d'oxygène les plaisirs aux seins sont
allés s'imposer 30 à 29 sur le terrain
du havre
une victoire qui permet aux joueurs de
sébastien roncalli de reprendre espoir
dans la course au maintien ils n'ont
plus qu'un point de retard sur le
premier non relégable
toujours en rugby mais cette fois ci en
honneur à l'union rugby centre 78 n'a
pas réussi à s'imposer contre les
premiers du classement clamart ce
dimanche et saint quentinois ont perdu
23 12 lui versé 78 toujours sixièmes
championnats sports de combat à présent
la ministre des sports a annoncé qu'elle
souhaitait légaliser la pratique des
arts martiaux mixtes en france pourtant
longtemps décriée est interdite pour
nous parler de cette nouvelle nous
recevons sur ce plateau haruna soumaré
le plaisir a été le premier vainqueur
officiel d'un combat de mma en france
éliane lamothe gérant du sdcl center est
également adepte du mma bonsoir
messieurs bonsoir
alors déjà on va revenir sur ce combat
que vous avez gagné haruna soumaré
c'était le 19 septembre 2015 à paris
pourquoi vous avez gagné ce premier
combat des m&a en france alors que
c'était illégal
à l'époque bas 300m un flou juridique du
coup ci a permis d'avoir de faire là
dans le d'organiser la compétition et
pourquoi j'ai gagné je pense qu a eu un
bon entraînement derrière un bon coach
une bonne salle un raccompagnement
je pense que voilà
enfin permis de d'arracher la victoire
alors le mma mail quel type de combat
technique demande quel type saas est un
sport tridimensionnel donc on va
retrouver des sports de percussion de
projection de travail au sol aujourd'hui
vous avez mal c'est un sport à part
entière
en fait c'est pas un mélange de sport
c'est un sport le mma on n'a pas besoin
d'avoir pratiqué la boxe autre chose
c'est ce serait comme mélanger le ping
pong et le tennis et le mma cdu et mes
bras est ce qu'on peut dire vous êtes
complet haruna à son pressing oui j'ai
fait beaucoup de sport du coup j'ai
acquis une certaine expérience
une certaine aisance dans beaucoup de
disciplines donc je vois que je suis
assez complet est bon qu'on a toujours à
améliorer certains points mais wells ça
sait compter est-ce que vous avez été
surpris de l'annoncé de la ministre
alors surpris surpris par le choix de la
fédération oui surpris par le fait
qu'elle soit le nom de boxe boxe le
choix qui a été donné c'est la boxe
anglaise s'était passé était donnée
gagnante du tout on est différents
sondages en fait à l'arrivée très très
très très loin
maintenant c'est un choix c'est un choix
et tant mieux parce qu'il fallait que ça
soit ça soit abandonnée délibéré il
fallait il fallait légiférer sur ça la
boxe anglaise c'est une fédé qui marche
depuis très longtemps qui a habitué à
organiser des galas prom pour un
professionnel un peu partout dans le
monde
si réellement ils les moyens sont mis
derrière pour développer le mma et et
tout ce que toute la partie éducative
parce que le combat c'est bien mais
c'est toute la partie éducative c'est
comment comment cadrer les enfants
correctement dans les salles
c'est si les moyens sont mis par la fédé
pour ça c'est génial dans tous les cas
c'est un grand pas pour le mma alors à
votre avis sur cette possible
légalisation en tout cas longuement de
chambre basse et rejoint un peu ce que
j'en dis il faut aller au bout d'un
moment se fixer sur une fédération et
légaliser pour avancer permettre à tous
les compétiteurs de
de se projeter vraiment sur du long
terme et peut-être pourquoi pas voir une
vraie carrière il est raccompagné par
des sponsors et autres
qu'est ce que vous répondez à ceux qui
disent encore aujourd'hui que la mma est
trop violent et de la motte
c'est à vous poser à mon avis depuis
hier plusieurs années je l'entends
depuis 20 ans cette question c'est
difficile de répondre à ça en fait de
ruptures ce cas là il faudrait leur
maître donc dans le mettre dans la
balance
la violence c'est quoi la notion de
violence oui c'est un sport de
compétition c'est un sport avec
percussions au cou il ya des coups
maintenant la violence la violence en
agressivité il n'y a pas de méchanceté
c'est un sport il ya des règles il ya un
cadre le long le reportage d'avant donc
le rugby la violence du rugby
aujourd'hui c'est un des sports il ya
plus de blessés ces labellisations sont
les plus chers c'est pas le mma au jour
dès qu'ils posent le plus de problèmes
on a des variables des variables on peut
être percuté les jambes comme le on peut
aller au sol
on peut avoir des stratégies de jeu qui
font qu'on on se blesse pas faim ça fait
quand même un paquet d'années qu'on est
dedans on arrive à avoir des
conversations on n'est pas défigurée et
c'est pas non c'est pas un sport violent
c'est un sport qui a besoin d'être
encadrés par des gens diplômés
compétents et justement pour pas tomber
dans une dérive
quelconque le fait d'avoir légiféré sur
ça ça ça va nous faire avancer
mais massa sera exactement la même chose
que partout dans le monde ou à votre
avis en france il y aura avec quelques
petites modifications
je ne sais pas j'espère sincèrement
qu'on va réussir à s'aligner sur le
monde
maintenant la france comme souvent on
est capable de faire exception
on est très fort en france pour tourner
aujourd'hui on n'a pas de toute façon le
l'effet d'annoncé a été donné c'est la
boxe anglaise mais rien n'a été
officiellement voté encore la parution
au journal officiel et pas fait
après il ya toute l'équipe à monter
derrière l'équipe d'encadrants il ya
tout allié tout le travail à faire
encore mais j'espère aussi qu'on sera
l'égal du monde
est ce que cette légalisation va
permettre à ce sport de se développer
encore plus forcément forcément il y
aurait entre vire ont cinquante et
soixante mille pratiquants en france
régulier je pense que le nombre
d'adhérents peut exploser peu évolué
vraiment parce que on sent qu'il ya
c'est l'un des sports de combat les plus
regardés au monde aujourd'hui un
enthousiasme à travers ce sport qui est
qui et pas le pont donc je pense que
vraiment il ya des possibilités de se
projeter pour les parents qui avait fait
dresser traité réticences au niveau 2 du
mma voilà à partir du moment où il ya un
accompagnement qu'on ait reconnu auprès
de deux ministres des sports je pense
qu'on pourra vraiment évolué dedans il
ya la mode combien de pratiquants dans
les yvelines inquantifiable c'est
clairement un camp tigréat le web
alors nous on est un peu plus de 500
adhérents sur la salle en sachant que en
fait ça passe d'abord s'engager ce qu'on
cesse thaïlandaise grappille tube
réserve et enfin on est on est surtout
plein de sport donc dire pratiquant des
menaces inquantifiable aujourd'hui comme
le mma n'existait pas on peut pas dire
le nombre de pratiquants il y a plein de
sport d'un plaisir un peu partout où il
ya des noms un peu un peu différent avec
des consciences japonaises chinoises
viennent vaudaine machin mais à la fin
on fait tout ça même chose du mma avec
avec un manche de pioche et là on peut
maintenant que le mma est une discipline
à part entière
désormais plus adhérent alors je moi mon
niveau
tout à son j'attends toujours plus
d'adhérents clairement mais le
surtout j'attends que les moyens soient
donnés par la fédé pour développer tout
le côté éducatif
à l'instar du judo qui a su mettre
l'accent sur les enfants parce que
l'avenir du des sports quels qu'ils
soient ces les enfants les combats gala
c'est bien c'est beau c'est cette belle
vitrine
mais l'avenir c'est les enfants celle
éducatif donc si l'accent est mis sur
l'éducatif et qu'on arrive à convaincre
les parents
de là du plus fort pouvoir éducatif de
ce sport toutes les valeurs qui sont
transmises à travers ce sport comme les
autres sports de combat alors oui ont
explosé sur clermont à l'onda soumaré
qu'est-ce que ça va changer concrètement
pour vous allez combattre ici en france
plutôt qu'à l'étranger vous allez
régulièrement à l'étranger pour réaliser
les combats ça sera en france maintenant
c'est une bonne question maintenant bon
on verra au niveau de ma carrière au
niveau des compétitions pour voilà j'ai
un certain âge maintenant j'ai certaines
priorités maintenant qu'ils sont
qui sont là essayer de voir comment
comment ça va évoluer mais bon
honnêtement moi je suis plus sur la fin
que sur le début de ma carrière
en tout cas je suis content pour les
nouvelles générations ce que ce que j'ai
pu inspirer de pendant pendant mes
compétitions pendant ma carrière j'ai
vraiment content que ça aboutisse à
quelque chose je tiens à féliciter et
remercier tous ceux qui ont pas qui ont
milité qui sont battus depuis plus de
vingt ans pour l'égalité mma qui nous
ont accompagnés à travers l'éducatif et
le sport lier les deux je pense que
c'est quelque chose de puissant pour les
générations à venir
et oui oui on verra on verra affaire à
suivre
merci à tous les deux dépassé sur ce
plateau on espère vous voir
prochainement dans un combat en france à
bouna sumaré non non crapa de vous
suivre sur tv 78 box maintenant la
carrière du tony hawk a pourrait prendre
un nouvel élan l'illinois de 27 ans
devrait signer officiellement dans les
prochains jours avec bob arum le
promoteur américain à la tête de la
société top top rank une entreprise qui
travaille que les plus grands boxeurs de
la planète et notamment certains tyson
fury ce partenariat yoka arômes devrait
ouvrir au boxeur de chanteloup les
vignes les portes des combats aux états
unis et d'un possible championnat du
monde le bilan de joka chez les
professionnels est actuellement de 7
victoires en 7 combats ont continué par
notre désormais à traditionnel jeu des
trois questions aujourd'hui c'est le
handballeur de plaisir benjamin modeste
qui est passé à sur le grill
après le match de ce week-end à regarder
[Musique]
pourquoi j'ai commencé l'emballage était
au tennis j'ai commencé par du tennis et
je me sentais un peu seul mon professeur
de sport au collège ma
un mât du jour m'a dit de venir à l'est
de la ja
un entraîneur qui est donc chercher du
club de versailles jean yves baudin j'ai
trouvé ça super sympa d'avoir un groupe
de potes et voilà c'était super sympa de
faire du rhône avec des copains et ça
fait maintenant presque 20 ans
[Musique]
mon meilleur souvenir assez compliqué
mais ce qu'il ya la montée avec plaisir
qui était attendu depuis de nombreuses
années par bon nombre de supporters et
je crois que c'est les larmes de
quelques-uns qui m'ont marqué et je
pense que je veux mettre en numéro
anciens
[Musique]
auditifs c'est ma pire plaisir au
niveau national et dans les années à
venir car monter en nationale 2 après je
suis pas là encore pendant dix ans parce
que je suis assez vieux on va dire
l'objectif personnel ce sera de devenir
entraîneur
on vous propose maintenant une pause des
tendances eux 7,8 sport c'est une
discipline du corps et de l'esprit
pratique et par de nombreux people et
sportif focus ce soir sur le hatha yoga
avec vous aurez les roses pour soir
alors que signifie le hatha yoga
alors le yoga est une école de
philosophie indienne le hard hat a veut
dire soleil et le tas signifie lune le
hatha yoga en fait c'est l'union du
soleil et de la lune c'est en fait le
yoga traditionnel idéal donc pour la
détente et pour la paix intérieure
alors il existe un dans les yvelines de
nombreuses associations qui proposent
des cours nous avons assisté à celui
proposé deux fois par semaine au
vélodrome de saint-quentin-en-yvelines
par l'association souffle de vie une
discipline vous allez l'entendre qui a
de nombreuses vertus
ça va apporter déjà un équilibre du
corps et de l'esprit
donc pour vraiment être bien équilibrée
dans sa vie et au delà de ça donc ça
permet d'assouplir le corps d'étirer le
corps donc ça résout pas mal de
problèmes de douleur
chronique ou de problèmes physiques et
en même temps bien sûr ça des grandes
vertus relaxant pour se détendre donc
anti stress et aussi donc ça a des
vertus de conscience de soi
combien de temps dure une séance
l'association souffle de vie propose des
séances d'une heure et demie elle est
composée d'un temps de recentrage un
temps d'échauffement un travail sur la
respiration un échauffement spécifique
pour la posture de la séance également
déséquilibre et puis pour terminer 15
milieu de relaxation et de méditation
qui peut pratiquer le hatha yoga
alors les enfants les personnes âgées
enfin tout le monde peut pratiquer ce
sport même vomi caire dire être un petit
peu raide et patrice aux places partent
c'est vrai c'est pas faux on mélange
tous les niveaux donc c'est une personne
que j'aime et fait du yoga à une
personne qui a de l'expérience en
rigolant reste toujours des buts en
apprend toujours on approfondit toujours
donc justement ce jeu ya des personnes
qui peuvent dire je suis pas sourd je
peux pas faire du cabanon justement
venait faire du yoga
parce qu'on s'assouplit on n'a pas
besoin d'être souple au départ on
s'assouplit on progresse
au nom de fil du temps alors si vous
aussi vous voulez être zen voici
quelques informations pratiques sachez
que le tarif est de 210 euros pour par
trimestre pour un cours par semaine
c'est l'état riche en qui sont qui sont
pratiqués pour pour le yoga
il n'y a pas besoin de beaucoup de
matériel un tapis une tenue confortable
un plaide pour la relaxation un petit
poussant si vous avez par exemple la
nuque fragile a sachez que l'association
souffle de vie donne des cours à
montigny le bretonneux à maurepas
également à montfort l'amaury toutes les
informations sur le site qui s'affiche
en bas de votre écran
merci aurélie pour cette découverte cela
donne envie d'essayer mais surtout pour
voir apparemment chaque séance de yoga
se termine par damas
namasté du cyclisme à présent une
épreuve de coupe du monde était organisé
au canada ce week-end sur la piste mathy
le gros s'est fait une belle frayeur la
pistarde qui s'entraîne régulièrement au
vélodrome de saint-quentin-en-yvelines a
chuté lors de la demi finale du keirin
apparemment plus de peur que de mal les
blessures seraient superficielles
elle passera des examens complémentaires
dans la semaine les pistes un français
eux remporté la vitesse par équipes avec
le trio du bce sky caleyron brembo et
lafargue les tricolores ont également
remporté la poursuite
on termine par une information à
cyclisme le coureur colombien de 23 ans
et gagnent bernal sera dans les yvelines
au mois de mars le vainqueur du dernier
tour de france a confirmé sa
participation pour le prochain paris
nice et sera au départ de plaisir
objectif défendre son titre acquis l'an
dernier il enregistré une vidéo pour ses
supporters avant tout la douleur
bonjour à tous je voulais vous dire que
je serai présent sur le paris-nice 2020
je suis impatient d'y retourner et faire
une belle course pour vous je me prépare
en ce moment spécialement pour cette
course
on se voit là bas la draille le paris
nice sera donc organisée le 8 mars
prochain au départ de plaisir pour cette
occasion la ville propose à ses
habitants de décorer la commune avec
leurs anciens vélos la maison des as des
ados pourrez personnaliser leur
bicyclette hors d'usagé avec des
nouvelles couleurs insolite
les vélos seront ensuite installés sur
des gros points et des espaces verts
vous pouvez déposer votre bicyclette
jusqu'au 31 janvier plus renseignements
sur le site de la mairie ch
on passe maintenant notre page agenda on
va parler à tennis dans cette page
agenda la winter cup u12 et l'équivalent
de la fed cup pour les jeunes est
programmée cette semaine à feucherolles
la compétition opposera les meilleurs
espoirs européens pour nous parler de ce
rendez vous nous recevons sur ce plateau
le président du comité des yvelines
francis eveillard et jean-françois
m'étais secrétaire général du comité des
yvelines et membre du comité de
direction de la ligue ile-de-france
bonsoir messieurs bonsoir alors je
comparais cette compétition à la fed cup
est ce que c'est le cas est ce que c'est
bon c'est le premier pas pour ces jeunes
filles vers la fed cup c'est la première
fois ils vont disputer pour les couleurs
de leur pays un match par équipe et ses
choix que c'est pour chaque jeune fille
même qu'on retrouve maintenant sur le
circuit international
ça reste un souvenir inoubliable cette
première avec les drapeaux les hymnes et
tout l'environnement justement de cette
compétition par nation est ce qu'on peut
parler du format ses deux simples et un
double seniors ça tout à fait donc ses
matches par équipe avec deux joueuses de
simple et suivi d'un double le format
petit peu delà de la fed cup la fed cup
alors pourquoi organiser cette
compétition à feucherolles c'est pour
promouvoir encore plus le délit civil
war bien sûr bien sûr le comité des
yvelines est fortement impliqué déjà
dans la formation des jeunes vers le
haut niveau international est également
deuxième atout est très très impliquée
aussi sur la pratique féminine et
développement du tennis féminin
donc on a là deux domaines dans lequel
le comité est fortement impliqué et
c'est une demande qu'on a fait depuis
deux ans auprès de la fédération pour
obtenir justement l'organisation d'une
compétition internationale
et on nous a proposé cette compétition
il faut dire aussi que cette compétition
par équipes nationales
c'est la seule en ile-de-france ile de
france qui représente près du quart du
tennis français
on n'a pas de
pétition de ce genre en ile de france et
la première combien nations seront
présentes sur ce rendez vous donc nous
aurons sept nations présentes dont
l'équipe de france donc delmarque france
georgy grand bretagne hongrie pologne et
portugal
c'est bien ça tout à trompe pas alors
l'équipe vainqueur va disputer les
phases finales c'est bien ça dure un peu
plus tard en grande bretagne les 14 et
16 février
les deux premières équipes toutes les
équipes ou avec classe et donc de 1,7 et
donc les deux premières équipes auront
un numéro 2 vont être qualifié pour la
phase justement finale en grande
bretagne au mois de février on voit les
images justement à l'écran en ce moment
des joueuses qui ont participé
injustement 7 winter cup il ya eu par
exemple lindsay davenport par exemple
steffi graf également voilà donc je veux
dire ça ça révèle des talents
cette estimation c'est on pourrait dire
que c'est une étape incontournable qu'on
va te toutes les les jeux ce qu'on
retrouve par la suite sont
obligatoirement passer par ce genre
d'étape et c'est de plus en plus
difficile pour nos jeunes par rapport à
ce qui se passait il ya une vingtaine
d'années maintenant au niveau du circuit
international
vu les contraintes au niveau physique
que le jeu du tennis et mines a
énormément changé
il devient pratiquement aussi attractif
que celui des hommes
ce qui n'était pas le cas il ya quelques
quelques années ça va vite ça tape fort
et puis physiquement c'est c'est faut
réellement la france at elle ses chances
sur cette compétition
bien sûr comme façon on sera là pour les
supporter évidemment comme le nombre que
les nouveaux bleus public nombreux qui
va venir
oui bien sûr la france a ses chances ce
sont des joueuses prometteuses
prometteuse on a trois joueuses
prometteuses et les ja hennissant
ophélie boulet et d'affiner mes beauty
péricard voilà on était avec des
collèges ont pris avec des classements
déjà pour des jeunes joueuses qui n'ont
pas encore 12 ans d'ailleurs aucune la
premier accord à cette vision c'est en
mars mais
elles ont des classements quand même
déjà de ce second thierry 4/6 pour la
numéro 1 et 5 6 5 6 pour la deux et la
trois donc c'est déjà des classements
vraiment d'eux au classement pour ces
jeunes est un peu celle viennent
d'horizons différents parce que une
viande la ligue du mauvais mounal
divionnais une haute vienne de la ligue
provence alpes côte d'azur et une de
bretagne quel sera le programme de la
compétition alors le programme de la
compétition dès le vendredi on aura
justement trois rencontres une première
rencontre qui aura lieu à partir de 12h
et deuxièmes et troisièmes rencontres
vers 13h30 et puis le dimanche 1er rang
compte à partir de 9h30 et deuxièmes et
troisièmes rencontres à partir de 11
heures
voilà le programme de la compétition le
dimanche sera également prévu une
animation vers 12h à peu près pour notre
une démonstration de notre élite
yvelinoise avec antoine ghibaudo donc
qui est qu'à 15 ans qui est classé 0 qui
est entraînée au comité divine c'est le
numéro un français numéro quatre mondial
et ses champions d'europe en 14 ans et
moins et vice champion du monde par
équipe aussi en 14 ans et moins il a
thomas mais miss au goût 14 en cas de
sixième numéro deux français et numéro
84 mondiale qui est dernier vainqueur
d'ailleurs du petit du tournoi tennis
europe à marcq en baroeul qui vient
d'avoir lieu
et puis une jeune fille lena thomas
église ya 14 ans 2 6e numéro 3 française
et numéro 5 100 mondial
dernière question est-ce que c'est
gratuit est ce que tout le monde peut
assister à la compétition en l'entrée
est libre et gratuite donc sur ces trois
jours et nous allons nous aurons la
chance aux puces le dimanche d'avoir
au comité la venue de la coupe de la fed
cup qui sera donc en exposition tout le
dimanche pourrait venir on pourra
prendre des photos avec donc ce qu'est
la coupe du monde féminine commerciale
et l'australie
merci beaucoup merci à tous les deux les
deux passés sur son plateau je vous
rappelle la date de cette winter cup le
tournoi sera organisé ce vendredi samedi
et dimanche à un fol
c'est déjà la fin de cette émission
merci de l'avoir suivi on se retrouve
lundi prochain pour un nouveau magazine
vice il a passé une excellente semaine
sportive
[Musique]